you know it hasn't actually been
canceled bright shut up okay Kojima's
probably leaving Konami which means that
I'm putting silent hill's on my let's
not get our hopes up pile along with so
many other games that haven't officially
been cancelled but have merely slipped
from our consciousness lost like tears
in the rain you really need to stop
watching Blade Runner but I liked it at
e3 2009 Sony announced that Rockstar
North was working on a ps3 exclusive
agent was revealed to be a first-person
stealth action game set during the Cold
War take two thought that it could even
be as big as grand theft auto appetites
were sufficiently wetted but we saw
nothing other than scraps of concept art
it was confirmed to still be in
development in 2011 and the trademark
was renewed a couple of years later but
in that time Rockstar North has been a
little preoccupied with a thing called
gta5 rockstar like all the best elusive
spies are keeping their cards close to
their chest and we've had no more intel
on agent Tim Bundy's ambitious follow-up
to the facially ambitious la noir has
been in production for years with a
speculative 2015 release dates but the
only thing we've seen from [ __ ] of the
Orient is this leaked gameplay found by
video gamer calm in 2011 developer team
bond I got liquidated and then bought by
Kennedy Miller Mitchell interactive in
2012 the game was said to still be in
development and managed to even snatch
funding from the Australian government
good news everyone
but then bad news everyone there was a
round of layoffs at the company and
rumors started spreading that new
publisher Warner Brothers had pulled out
of the deal cause we haven't seen [ __ ]
of the Orient in a couple years it's
likely that it's just dead in the water
well what about brothers-in-arms furious
for gearbox announced it at e3 2011 and
the inglorious basterds inspired
first-person shooter was due to be
published by Ubisoft and released the
following year fans weren't so keen on
its liberal take on historical accuracy
and at PAX Prime 2012 gearbox head Randy
Pitchford claimed that the game was now
a new IP and the more would be unveiled
during Gearbox's community day later
that year which it wasn't I'm still
waiting Randy every e3 I wait for mr.
caffeine I should Tyler or Eve kill mode
to say just one more thing and show off
their final surprise hoping that it will
finally be Beyond Good and Evil
- every year nothing we did get a
trailer for the sequel but no actual
confirmation that the game was in
development its creator michel ancel
kept shrugging assuring fans that it was
still happening and hinted at a next-gen
release but with on sales attention set
firmly on Raymond and now his new
independent studio wild sheep I guess
it's time to pack up the camera and put
this one to bed
so yeah silent Hills may not have been
officially cancelled but with that whole
Kojima Konami fallout we heard what was
happening to Metal Gear nothing on
silent Hills so no I'm not overly
confident but del Toro was involved well
he's got a great track record huh still
way on insane by the way oh yeah
but hey Pacific Rim - because you know
what hasn't actually been through my
eyes got really watery from all the
emotion from the scene from the exit
from the acting